[Music]
[Music]
what happened
after the great calamity in the 100
years link was recovering from his
injuries at the shrine of resurrection
how did the people of hyrule cope with
the loss of the once powerful kingdom
what happened to ganon's armies and how
did the various races move on and
rebuild after such a cataclysmic event
by the time breath of the wild's main
story picks up many of the initial
survivors of the great war had long
since passed away and with the exception
of a select few most had only heard the
bone-chilling stories which were passed
on from generation to generation and
never witnessed any of it themselves
there exists a plethora of videos and
articles which detail some of the
stories from post-war hyrule such as the
life of robbie and his fellow scientists
and their research into the ancient
technology the story of cass his mentor
and their quest for the ancient songs or
the life of the former yiga spy dorian
and the tragedy that took place after
his defection from the clan and so on so
in this video we'll do things a bit
differently instead of focusing on
individual stories most of which tie
directly into the main narrative we will
attempt to paint a broader picture of
how hyrule and its inhabitants as a
whole re-established reconnected and
developed their culture in the many
decades following the tragic fall of the
highly inceed of power things which
don't necessarily have a big impact on
the main narrative but simply serve to
enrich this iteration of hyrule ever so
slightly with the help of breath of the
wild's hidden backstories as well as its
complementary book creating a champion
we will move up the timeline of events
to see how hyrule slowly evolved right
up until the moment link wakes up and
the story of breath of the wild kicks in
as a side note the events of the
calamity itself will not be covered in
this video however i will provide
sources at the very end in case you want
to learn more about the finer details of
the war i will also refrain from going
too in-depth into individual aspects and
the theories surrounding them as some of
these on their own could easily take up
an entire video i want to keep things
moving at a reasonable pace with that
said let's see what we can find out
about the aftermath of the great
calamity
the overarching timeline of breath of
the wild consists of four primary time
periods the distance passed 10 000 years
ago 100 years ago which is when the
calamity takes place and the present day
when link wakes up from his stasis and
the story of the game picks up our focus
will solely be on this part right here
from the end of the war to the beginning
of breath of the wild the instant zelda
sealed ganon and herself inside the
walls of hyrule castle can be considered
as the moment the day of the calamity
officially ended as it is here that
ganon loses control over his armies and
the threat of his presence is
temporarily gone and as mentioned before
link opening his eyes after his 100 year
recovery is where the next chapter in
hyrule's history starts there's only one
instance where the time period between
the war and the present day is
specifically mentioned and even given a
proper name the age of burning fields
and is only spoken about by one person
an old woman named uma who lives in
hattano village the name's origin and
implication is never really explained
the war would have left the fields of
central hyrule burning but obviously not
for 100 years more like a few days or
weeks at best so perhaps it's a
reference to the time period after the
flames of war faded and civilization had
to rebuild from the ashes alternatively
since the name is only used by one
person from the hattano village area it
could also only apply to this area
specifically but to avoid skipping ahead
too much we'll touch upon that later
when we talk more about hateno instead
let's start at the very beginning as
stated before the moment ganon was
sealed away he essentially lost control
over his entire army it forced him into
a vegetative state meaning any machine
or monster influenced by his malice was
suddenly no longer linked to ganon's
consciousness which is why the attack on
hyrule settlements stopped even though
there were still plenty of his minions
left alive when it comes to the
guardians we know for a fact that some
remained operational despite no longer
being controlled directly by ganon
robbie's memoirs make this clear as he
describes himself dispatching several
lone guardians while on his journey from
kakariko to akula which is after the war
was already over for quite a while the
guardians were still corrupted by malice
and thus still dangerous but no longer
coordinated as an army and only attacked
when approached the divine beasts were a
different story however unlike the
guardians who operate autonomously the
beasts require a pilot in order to stay
up and running after the champions were
killed ganon used his four blights which
are nothing more than an extension of
himself to pilot them with ganon gun
these manifestations of malice
dissipated alongside him thus without a
pilot the divine beasts fell completely
dormant and wouldn't move for many
decades to come as for the hordes of
monsters under the influence of malice
they too seemed to have stopped their
advance on the people of hyrule as soon
as ganon was gone the majority of them
split up into groups and set off in
different directions many bonded
together creating small clans all over
hyrule seeking shelter inside caves
abandoned ruins or built their own these
clans would mostly stick to themselves
no longer were they marching upon
settlements as an army instead basic
survival such as hunting became the
priority as with the guardians the many
monsters still remain dangerous when
approached and they will prove to be a
strong competitor for future travelers
although ganon's temporary defeat at the
hands of the princess was a necessary
and crucial victory and ultimately led
to a successful rematch 100 years later
the victory itself was bittersweet as
the most dominant race in hyrule and the
prime target of ganon's attack the
hylians were by far hit the hardest
central hyrule which was home to most of
their settlements was left burning
hyrule castle town and many other
settlements leveled hyrule's one's
massive army decimated even far away
hylian settlements such as tabantha
village lake illuminy and the shadow
hamlet did not escape the carnage the
first days after the calamity were
likely chaotic depressing and mostly
consisted of shock and grief hundreds
perhaps thousands of people either lay
dead or were forcibly displaced from
their homes during the evacuation of
central hyrule as they fled for their
lives with ganon's forces right on their
heels they left behind friends family
their belongings even the memories of
their once peaceful lives creating a
champion depicts three prominent
evacuation routes during the attack one
from central hyrule to hateno village
from gaponga to kakariko and from the
east of castletown to akla citadel
though the latter is described as having
consisted mostly of military evacuees
who prepared to make a final stand at
the citadel rather than civilians
meaning that most of the civilian
refugees were given asylum at kakariko
and tateno alone we don't know exactly
how many survivors there were but when
looking at this map which shows the
hylian presence in hyrule before and
after the calamity it becomes clear that
the vast majority were not among the
lucky ones in a single day a massive
regional power the biggest regional
power in hyrule was reduced to a handful
of survivors as for the other races they
were a lot more fortunate aside from the
loss of their champion there are no
other major casualties that we know of
during the actual day of the calamity
this might confuse those who played age
of calamity as here we see a massive war
between ganon's army and all of hyrule's
races but keep in mind that this game
takes place in an alternate timeline one
in which the power of foresight as well
as some other major plot devices allowed
them to bond together resulting in a
victory instead of a defeat in breath of
the wild's timeline this didn't happen
here everyone was caught completely off
guard and no army besides the hylian
army was ever even mobilized as far as
we know this was devastating for the
hylians but to a certain extent
favorable for the other races goron city
rideau village gerudo town kakariko
village and zora's domain remained
completely untouched by ganon's army if
there were any casualties among these
races these would have been limited to
the few that were visiting the hylian
capital that day that isn't to say that
they were spared any shock or grief
though the loss of their champions was
in some cases enough to send their
entire culture into a state of disarray
they were left leaderless lost a
prominent warrior or part of their royal
lineage most famously of course being
the loss of princess mifa which caused
the entire zora race to fall into a
state of anger and misery for many
decades to come as the smoke cleared
around centro hyrule and the bordering
provinces affected by the attack the
dead were honored and laid to rest the
four champions were each remembered and
memorialized accordingly within the
traditions of their people and their
favored weapons retrieved from within
their own respective divine beasts to be
passed on as for the hylians there
wasn't a whole lot they could do central
hyrule had become a dangerous wasteland
with monsters and stray guardians still
wandering around attempting to retrieve
bodies from this area would have been a
death sentence despite this it is made
clear that someone took the risk to bury
the deceased king of hyrul who is
speculated to have made his final stand
at the tempo of time atop the great
plateau his grave is found atop mount
hylia in the same general area there's
no source which confirms who is
responsible for this noble act but if we
had to make a guess it was likely the
shika the sheikah whose hometown was
spared the destruction and now served as
a refuge for the hylian evacuees were
present at the great plateau the moment
the war ended more specifically two
sheikah warriors robbie and pura were
all at the shrine of resurrection to
place the mortally wounded link inside
just as zelda sealed ganon inside the
castle so it is likely that they were
the ones responsible for the king's
burial though we don't know if this
happened right after they put the hero
to rest or sometime in the days after
and this is likely the state hyrule was
left in for the coming days weeks
perhaps even months a time of mourning
attending the wounded and figuring out
where to go from here and it would take
a while before any attempts to rebuild
society were made
as the rest of hyrule slowly recovered
from the initial shock the hylians had
another problem to deal with namely
where to house all these refugees which
were now left homeless and stranded well
as we can deduce from the game itself
kakariko village was not suitable for
permanent housing most chica were still
alive so there would have been very
little vacancy not to mention that
kakuriko lies embedded within the
mountains leaving no room for expansion
of the village food would have also been
a problem as the shika only have so much
room for agriculture inside their tiny
home town the only two hylian villages
that were still standing at this point
were hatteno and lu ellen lorelen lies
secluded and was spared any damage or
casualties from the war so again vacancy
would have been a problem it also has
its own distinct culture and almost
entirely depends on fishing to survive
so hateno really was the only viable
option therefore in time the refugees at
kakariko were relocated to hatteno and
this is where the story about hateno
becomes clear the woman who we mentioned
before named uma states that she wasn't
alive during the calamity however she
did grow up during the early years of
post-war hattano she explains that the
village was a lot smaller back then in
that agriculture was almost non-existent
in this region however slowly but surely
the people of ateno started cultivating
the land growing more livestock building
windmills and even she herself
contributed to the study and budding of
plants as she came of age hattano became
in her words self-sufficient this would
indicate that before the calamity heteno
was mostly relying on trade with central
hyrule which makes sense but now that
the hylian capital was reduced to ash
the village had to learn to take care of
itself especially now that its
population had increased due to other
refugees this is also why i stated
before that the name age of burning
fields may not be a reference to the
burning down of central hyrule and might
not even be used as a term outside
hatteno burning fields could instead
refer to the cultivation of the land
surrounding the village a common
technique used to create fertile land is
what's known as slash and burn
agriculture where existing vegetation is
cut down and then burned creating a
nutrient-rich layer that renders the
soil fertile and suitable for
agriculture so perhaps this is why the
period after the calamity is referred to
in this manner by the people of ateno
either way hateno becoming
self-sufficient was likely one of the
first steps in rebuilding driven by pure
necessity but as we've come to find out
the hylians never managed to even come
close to returning to their former glory
not even the nearby defense post of fort
hatteno which played a vital role in
keeping the village safe during the
calamity was ever refurbished save for
some crude wooden patchwork made out of
tree trunks even after 100 years it
still looks as damaged as it did right
after the war creating a champion states
that this is because all of hyrule's
highly skilled stonemasons who were
responsible for the grandeur of hyrule's
former capital perished during the
calamity and thus the knowledge of
complex stone masonry was lost and even
if that weren't the case the people in
this region apparently lack the funds to
make comprehensive repairs to the fort
and the game actually does reflect this
explanation most houses in ateno are
crude and simplistic compared to those
that existed back at the capitol and
have little to no ornaments or fancy
designs even more notably is that in the
later stages of the age of burning
fields the construction workers at
hatteno have started developing a brand
new building style which consists of a
so-called form follows function
simplistic easy to build and quickly to
take down again if needed we can see
some seemingly unoccupied prototypes of
these houses at the edge of the village
they are made almost entirely out of
wood rather than stone these are also
the same type of houses used to
construct terrytown later on the time in
which the hylian refugees started to
settle in ateno is also when impa rabi
and pura decided to part ways and live
separate lives far away from each other
the reason given is that in the unlikely
event that kakariko would come under
attack prematurely either by the yiga or
because ganon broke free sooner than
expected all three could potentially be
killed in one fell swoop they wanted to
make sure that at least one of them
would still be alive by the time link
would awaken so they could assist him in
his quest to defeat ganon once and for
all in the weeks before their departure
robbie and pura had been scouting the
east of hyrule in search of pockets of
ancient energy which were needed to fuel
their research a search which according
to robbie they were lucky to survive
they were successful though and managed
to find two suitable locations one close
to hatteno where pura would construct
her laboratory and another in akula
close to an old lighthouse which robbie
soon called home meanwhile impal would
stay behind in kakariko village the
other races of hyrule never really had
to rebuild since their homes remained
unscathed but some did experience
significant changes in particular the
gorons sometime after the calamity daruk
was added to their collection of
important figures from their history
cementing his impact on their culture as
a way to honor him shortly after a new
prominent figure rose up among the
gorons bluto a young goron visionary who
realized that the gorons could prosper
if they expanded their mining operations
and thus established the goron group
mining company which would soon turn the
mining of ore into a thriving business
venture for the gorons the zora remained
bitter a statue of mifa was erected at
the central square of their domain and
they continue to honor her death
annually the council of elders blamed
the hylians and in particular the fallen
hero for the loss of their beloved
champion the hylian's failed plan to
defeat ganon which ultimately led to the
death of their princess stirred up a
strong anti-hylian mindset among many
zora especially the elders a sentiment
which would persist even to the present
day as a result of this the zora
isolated themselves from the rest of the
world for many decades to come the
history of the rito during this age is a
lot less defined than others from what
we can gather most of them stuck to
their own kind and continue to live
their lives in the tabantha region
rivali's memory and stories of his skill
were passed on but not memorialized like
the others no statues no wall
decorations or anything of swords can be
found in and around their home though
like the other champions his favorite
weapon the great eagles bow has been
preserved and passed down by dorito
leadership rivalli's honor is mainly
that of a warrior's tale a role model
for a young aspiring rido soldiers to
one day hone their skills to his level
as opposed to the other races the gerudo
never really got to enjoy a time of
peace although the calamity was over
they remained in a constant skirmish
with the ganon loyalists the yiga clan
they've been at war with each other
since even before the calamity as both
groups call the desert province home
it's not clear if any significant
battles have taken place between the two
during this time or if it remained as a
stalemate but apparently the tensions
between the two never let up from this
point on time crept by the gorons
continued to mine the zora and rito kept
it themselves the gerudo continued to
defend their home the highly instructed
the safety of their villages and the
shika continued their research and
patiently awaited the hero's return
meanwhile the ruins of the once
prosperous kingdom slowly started being
consumed and erased by nature exposed to
the elements moss and ivy covered the
ornate stonework wooden houses collapsed
and decayed rivers and lakes started
expanding
flooding buildings and even entire
villages monsters made their home in and
around the once prominent symbols of
hylian power and a few stray guardians
continued to roam around unchecked
hyrule had become a dangerous place and
the trauma of the calamity still
lingered in the minds of hyrule's
inhabitants because of this it's
unlikely that there was a lot of
traveling going on in the first few
decades of post-war hyrule leaving the
former kingdom largely barren
disconnected and isolated however it
wouldn't be long until a massive shift
would start to take place
[Music]
decades after the war that changed
hyrule forever a shift in mindset
started to settle in especially among
the hylians by this time a whole new
generation had come of age people who
were not alive to witness the horrors of
the great war all they knew were the
stories hence this new generation of
hylians were much bolder and less
fearful than their parents and
grandparents who still remember the
terror of that infamous day despite the
dangers lurking across hyrule people
started craving adventure they didn't
want to spend the rest of their lives
cowering behind walls just because of
some stories about a war they never
experienced consequently more and more
people slowly started trying their luck
out there in the wild from treasure
hunters to merchants aspiring
archaeologists and journalists all
started to abandon their comfortable
village life to explore the world left
behind by their ancestors in order to
make travel faster easier and more safe
an old network of stables built
alongside the many roads was
re-established to accommodate weary
travelers horses were being caught in
bread old gear collected and restored
new gear crafted and sold slowly but
surely the hylian started to once again
make their presence known across hyrule
it is clear that a similar network of
stables existed before the calamity the
company attributed to the stables is
called a pona company and creating a
champion states that they are quote an
established all-encompassing horse goods
maker with over 150 years of experience
but many of the modern day stables had
to have been built or at least rebuilt
after the calamity as a lot of them are
found in places that were completely
overrun by the guardians such as on
blatchery plane on the way to gopanga
right next to oculus citadel and so on
so the most likely scenario is that as
this new generation of hylians started
venturing out into the world again they
either re-established the legacy of
their ancestors company or the stables
which had survived the calamity started
rebuilding in old and new locations to
accommodate all these new travelers
breathing new life into a pona company
that way nevertheless most of these new
adventures did seem to realize quickly
that central hyrule was a no-go even
decades after the war the province
remained dangerous the many monster
camps and especially stray guardians
likely discouraged most hylians from
setting foot too deep into the area and
it shows say for a few stables at the
very edge of the province it's rare to
encounter anyone the closer you get to
hyrule castle and no infrastructure or
living spaces have been built on the
fields themselves still a few daredevils
were crazy enough to go the extra mile
yes some people actually went inside
hyrule castle town and even the castle
itself from the vantage point of
present-day hyrule this seems like an
absolute death wish but we learned from
various sources that hiro castle wasn't
always as dangerous as it is now no
doubt it was still no cakewalk but it
was apparently quite common for people
to snoop around hyrule castle in the
decades prior to link's return there are
no less than two articles inside the
rumor mill which is sort of a gossip
newspaper which mentions secrets that
people have discovered while roaming
around the abandoned hyrule castle such
as the existence of king rome's secret
room the location of zelda's laboratory
and the discovery of weapons belonging
to the royal guard who all perished
during the calamity we also find an
empty campsite inside the castletown
ruins another hint to the presence of
hylians in this area but forget news
articles and old campsites we have
actual first-hand accounts like this
woman named parsi who states that she
used to sneak into hyrule castle in
search of treasure it's also from her
that we learned that the castle was a
lot less dangerous than it is nowadays
stating quote i used to sneak in there
to salvage ancient treasures but it's
too dangerous to go in there now these
days it's surrounded by an eerie mist
and savage machine-like creatures back
when it was safer i went in looking for
this ultra rare equipment that belonged
to the royal guard this indicates that
there were barely any active guardians
present at the castle in the early days
after the calamity if any at all as such
hyrule castle used to be a treasure
trove for those brave enough to venture
inside and there's another fairly
important figure who is known to have
entered hyrule castle after the calamity
the infamous yet elusive miscode the
great bandit a thief who managed to get
his hands on a plethora of ancient
treasures once belonging to the royal
family it's unclear exactly when he
managed to obtain his treasures or if
he's even alive in the present day but
it is yet another example that during
this era one could set foot in hyrule
castle without immediately being
vaporized by dozens of guardian lasers
these early expeditions inside hyrule
castle are a true testament to the
mindset of the travelers of this era
none of these people had experienced the
calamity heck most of them had ever even
seen the ruins of hyrule's former
capital with their own eyes and likely
only heard about its existence from
stories passed on by the village elders
i can only imagine the excitement these
early explorers felt when they first saw
this empty decrepit megalithic structure
looming over the horizon as they first
set foot onto the fields of central
hyrule the same place from which their
ancestors had to flee for their very
lives the great plateau meanwhile
remained totally unexplored a complete
collapse of its main entrance prevented
anyone from accessing the sacred site
leaving the temple of time eastern abbey
as well as the recovering hero
undisturbed
[Music]
from this moment on the ball just kind
of kept rolling the first generation of
travelers eventually grew old had
children who would also go on their own
personal journeys discovering ancient
sites setting up shops hunting for
treasure while others prefer to settle
down inside their respective villages as
for the other races with the exception
of the zora they too started coming out
of their shell more and more rito gorons
and gerudo started visiting each other's
territory again trading and even tourism
became more abundant despite large parts
of hyrule still remaining an abandoned
ruined ghost town a shadow of its former
self the landscape was slowly but surely
coming to life again hyrule was in a
sense reconnecting again with the
exception of the zora people who
actually witnessed the calamity started
becoming more and more rare around this
time with the passing of each generation
the last survivors of the great war
slowly died out for some quicker than
others the rito are said to have an
average lifespan of only about 50 years
old so by this time they are already at
least two generations ahead of everyone
else making the memory of the calamity
even more distant the goron's gerudo and
hylians all have lifespans similar to
that of real life humans bluto the
entrepreneur who started the goron
mining group and had since become the
new chief of the gorons was born
post-calamity and even the oldest of
garuda women link meets in the air of
the wild don't seem to have been alive
during the great war the sheikah's
lifespan surpasses that of the average
hylian goron and gerudo but not by a
huge amount averaging around 120 maybe
130 years old even so impa pura and
robbie are still alive to tell the tale
and there was even another shika
survivor who still persisted around this
time that being an unnamed poet who
worked at the courts of hyrule castle
pre-calamity he was likely a bit older
than impapura and robbie as he didn't
survive long enough to witness link's
return but was still around long enough
that he was able to meet the traveling
rito minstrel cass and pass on the
ancient songs to him this likely only
happened a few years maybe a few decades
before link's return as again rito
usually don't live past 50 and cass
still looks pretty lively and has
seemingly become a father quite recently
the zora are the only ones who have an
absurdly long lifespan compared to the
other races it's never stated exactly
how old they can get but king dorafan is
said to have been on the throne for at
least two centuries and still going
strong with the exception of the very
young every zorah present at the domain
has experienced the calamity prince said
on being among the youngest survivors as
he was only a small child at the time
his generation is also a lot less
stubborn when it comes to the reputation
of the hylians however the elders have
still insisted on keeping the hylians at
a distance even after all these years
the loss of mifa still remained a
sensitive topic within the domain the
only zoran known to have interacted with
other races after the calamity is prin
saidon who at some point is said to have
killed a giant octarock which was
plaguing lorelan village and stories
about his heroics are still passed on
among the people of laurellin but other
than that the zora still remains
secluded the only time they seem to
venture outside their domain is to train
at sea or catch fish at lake hylia
[Music]
as the age of burning fields drew to a
close another big shift was about to
take place in hyrule this time for the
worst unbeknownst to most people the c1
ganon had gradually been weakening over
time as zelda slowly started to lose
grip on the demon king the seal had
reached a critical point and ganon
started being able to exert his
influence once again as link became
closer and closer to regaining
consciousness so did ganon and his
armies monsters grew ever more restless
and their numbers increased just as they
had done so right before the calamity
more and more ancient machines started
springing back to life and hyrule castle
castle town and the surrounding fields
became increasingly dangerous and even
less accessible but most unnervingly the
colossal divine beasts which had laid
dormant for close to a century now
suddenly started to reanimate as ganon
started showing signs of life so did his
blights within the four giants though
not yet fully under his control the
beasts clumsily started causing trouble
in their respective provinces varudania
started stomping around the base of the
volcano causing eruptions of molten rock
to rain down on the goron city area
faruta planted itself inside east
reservoir lake spouting water upwards in
a torrential downpour potentially
flooding the reservoir breaking the dam
and washing away zora's domain in other
parts of hyrule vametto took to the
skies above rideau village shooting down
anyone who might approach preventing
easy access to the skies and vanabora
started waltzing around the desert
whipping up sand creating sandstorms as
well as a barrage of lightning the slow
revival of the demon king signaled the
imminent return of the hero something
the yiga had been waiting for they had
been keeping tabs on the shika in the
many decades since the calamity and
through their spies knew that the hero
was still alive and that the shika were
anticipating his return now they ready
themselves to serve ganon once again
dispatching assassins to look for the
hero after decades of rebuilding
reconnecting and rediscovering the
remnants of the broken kingdom a second
showdown is now on the horizon meanwhile
at the shrine of resurrection a familiar
voice echoes through the darkness
open your eyes
[Music]
hey there everyone thank you for
watching this video if you want to learn
more about the events of the calamity
itself there's a few sources i can
recommend first off is the complete
breath of the wild timeline by nintendo
black crisis which covers not only the
calamity but also some of the same
events we've discussed here as well as
the story of the present day next are
two videos by celtic about the siege on
oculus citadel as well as the so-called
miracle at fort hatteno which both
provide detailed descriptions of two
prominent battles which took place
during the war and as a shameless plug
for my own content i can also recommend
watching my series called the heroes
path of which you can find the full
playlist on my channel page although
this series was intended to be sort of a
prediction for the story and gameplay of
h of calamity if you ignore the gameplay
speculations it does go into a lot of
detail about specific events like the
evacuations certain battles and
particularly the journey each important
character underwent that day and all
this information is based on the game as
well as creating a champion speaking of
age of calamity you could play well age
of calamity although the story takes
place in an alternate timeline and thus
isn't accurate when it comes to the
outcome it is still the closest you can
get to experiencing the type of chaos
that went on during the attack as well
as a way to see many of hyrule's famous
buildings and settlements before they
were turned to rubble so yeah that's
about it as always a big thanks to my
mods and of course my patreon supporters
and channel members of which i have a
couple of new names to announce thank
you so much to my cousins mikey and
deimos christopher sinclair brian tygy
gypsy macy hylian historian thomas
streamer and disaster link thank you all
so much for the support it means the
world to me and that is all for now this
is dawn signing off and
have a good one
you